[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator TV
and broadcast on the 15th of June I'm
Katie balls The Spectators political
editor and your host for this week
coming up on the show
the Tory Civil Wars have started again
with Boris Johnson locked in battle of
Rishi c-neck this week can the former
prime minister take his successor down
I'll be speaking to a spectator editor
Fraser Nelson and pollster professor
John Curtis
and Boris Johnson is not the only former
leader causing trouble across the pond
Donald Trump is trying to boost his
re-election campaign by claiming that
he's the victim of a legal Witch Hunt
I'll be joined by a spectator Deputy
editor Freddie gray to hear about
Trump's trials
and staying in the U.S over the last
week New Yorkers have been subjected to
scenes straight out of Blade Runner as
the city is covered with smoke from
wildfires in Canada but is climate
change to blame I'll be speaking to
spectator columnist Lionel Shriver and
the atmosphere scientist Professor
Clifford Mass
for also be turning our sights to Russia
where has Putin gone in the last few
weeks of the war it seems that the
president is missing in action I'll be
speaking to Russian experts Aaron
Matthews and Anna aratanyan
and finally our boys boarding schools
are dying breed Andrew Cunningham a
former teacher at Radley college has
written for spectated life that there
are fewer and fewer boys only schools he
joins the show to tell me why and we
discuss if co-ed is the way forward
before we get going thanks to our
sponsors Canada wealth management for
supporting the show can a quarter
experienced wealth planners and
investment managers who offer unwavering
support and challenging times visit can
do wealth.com for more information
and if you enjoy spectator TV then do
subscribe to our YouTube channel just
click the Subscribe button at the bottom
of the video and tap the Bell icon so
you never miss an episode
first up The Fragile truth between Boris
Johnson and Rishi Scenic is officially
over the two men have been locked in a
public battle over the issue of boris's
resignation honors list and now we're
looking at free by-elections down the
line
I've written about boris's revenge in
this week's spectator cover article
joining me to discuss his fate and what
for Rishi sunak our spectator editor
Fraser Nelson and Pauline gory professor
John Curtis
Fraser John thank you for joining
spectator TV this week Fraser we're back
to Tori's Psycho Drama it's been a
couple of weeks
how damaging do you think this latest
episode is uh Boris Johnson's decision
to step down not alone but with two of
his backers therefore meaning free
by-elections for Rishi sunak well I do
think that this is quite damaging
varicious because his whole promise to
the country was that he was the The
Bookmark the era of Tory Psycho Drama
that chapter had closed and he was going
to open a new chapter of stability and
this was the point where it was changed
and now when the conservatives as a
party just look like a warring tribal
mess yet again
um and one of the things you see in your
cover of story Katie is it could get
even worse and of course we all know
that when Richardson neck became leader
he was in his own words put in rather
than one election so he knew that he
couldn't really get into much of a
personal mandate he was the loser not
the winner of the contests with members
and and so he figured he had to keep all
of his various um Tory factions happy so
you can see in his cabinet this was not
a sunec cabinet this was what he thought
was a truce brokerage between various
warning Tory tribes they all got their
man in a certain position and that would
be fine of course what borders Jones
once it was his honors list so
um all along where she's been sort of
waiting and waiting and waiting and now
he said sorry Boris you're not going to
get things that you wanted specifically
Nadine Doris into the House of Lords and
at which point and Boris decides okay
that's it it's war and then we see the
sheer power of Tory spite now looking at
this is it's pretty weird do you think
what's boris's agenda what does he
actually want to achieve is he trying to
get I don't know Ben Wallace in his
leader or something like that and the
more you ask questions the more you find
out there is no agenda other than simply
to weaken Rishi sinek and to
re-establish in the public mind the
words conservative and shambles and to
make it harder for a synag to claim that
she has been able to move on now I would
enter this the financial bank drop of
the guild markets really quite
significant and there was a few weeks
when trust was prime minister where we
were saying okay Liz trust puts up the
guilt rights look at this it's 4.3
percent the markets are are pushing up
everybody's mortgages she has to go she
has to go because the markets say uh
Rishi sunec he'll be the market
Whisperer as soon as he comes along
he'll tell the markets everything's
going to be fine and they'll calm down
now that was The Narrative of the end of
last year but now the inflation
expectations are going up the guilt
yards are going up all of a sudden
people think the bank rates are going to
Peak at 5.75 percent the new mortgages
if you're trying to buy a house right
now incredibly expensive so sunak has
failed on two of his main pledges one
the hill count the markets to the hokan
the Tories
John when it comes to I suppose how the
public look at this do you think your
average voter will tell the difference
between Boris Johnson causing problems
to Rishi sunak and general Tory problems
we saw Richardson act this week uh
ultimately hit back at Boris Johnson
Monday when he's speaking at Tech week
Boris Johnson asked me to do something
that I wasn't prepared to do because I
didn't think it was right and if people
don't like that then tough it has won
some praise from his party but I do
wonder how much cut for it has more
generally
well I think the first thing we have to
ask ourselves is how much cut through
all of this is having uh with the wider
public
um we've not had much opinion parting so
far
um but we've had three opinion polls
come out that were conducted wholly or
partly since Boris Johnson's resignation
was announced on Friday evening together
but that's somewhat incendiary
resignation statement and it has to be
said that so far conservative support
has not gone up and it's not gone down
um and perhaps we should remember that
given the conservative party is already
at a pretty low point in the opinion
polls there is perhaps a limit to the
damage that can be done now I hear a lot
of what phrases says and clearly the
bile actions are unwelcome clearly any
discontent within the party that is
unwelcome but I suspect that so far as
the longer term future of the
conservative party is concerning the
British Surah as a concerned it's what's
happening to inflation it's what
happening to interest rates that is
probably the biggest story so far as
those prospects are a concerned because
in the end Mr sunak one of the things
he's staked his reputation on so far is
the public is concerned is getting
inflation done and by implication there
so also beginning to get uh interest
rates down now while in a sense the
economy so far has not done as badly as
either the bank of England or the obr
were anticipating for the early months
of this year the inflation numbers are
not so good and that could mean in the
end uh of course the conservatives
difficulty so far as Livingstone just
next year
against that
um you know
my my honest feeling about the whole
Boris Johnson thing is that Boris
Johnson is an outcome focused person he
wants to achieve what he wants to get
done now for a long time that worked
fine so if you proud Parliament
um and even though in the end the courts
say he did what you did was illegal you
don't suffer politically but because at
least half the country I.E those who
wanted brexit to be implemented were in
favor of what he did was anybody going
to question debatable procure public
procurement policies during the covert
pandemic no we all wanted the pandemic
to be sorted sooner rather than later
and in the end the bets on the vaccines
worked but where did Mr Johnson's
political fortunes begin to unravel well
what was it it was trying to bend the
rules to enable a conservative MP who
had been found to have broken the rules
on lobbying to be saved from his
punishment now one thing we know there
is no public constituency out there that
says we should make life easier for MPS
who have second jobs and we're quite
happy to see the rules broke in all to
do so and frankly I don't think there's
much of a constituency out there that
believes that the rules on the on the on
the delivery of honors should be bent in
other words the cause is belli that Mr
Johnson is now pursuing looks to me as
fragile as the one with the Aaron
Patterson Affair let alone uh the
position uh over over party gate and I
so beyond that I would say at the end of
the day you know if Mr cynuck is going
to have any chance at all of being able
to win the next election one of the
things he's going to have to do is to
draw pretty substantial clear blue water
between both the Johnson Administration
and the trust Administration and it may
well be that in the longer run this
actually will enable him to do so
certainly if in the end when we see the
report from the Privileges committee and
if it says Christmas we anticipate and
the Prime Minister basically indicates
that he accepts the Judgment of the
Privileges committee that may well help
him in that endeavor and Fraser this is
an argument we hear from optimists
surrounding Rishi sunak which is
effectively if you look at what came up
as the most frequent complaint during
local elections according to many
cancers out on the doorstep and and
others it was uh Liz truss Boris Johnson
The Fallout and Richard that has already
differentiated himself from Liz truss in
terms of a different economic approach
even though as you point out the
guiltyards are now back to some of the
levels and secondly he has now perhaps
through the intervention this week
distanced himself from Boris Johnson so
there is a chance this could be a moment
where he manages to actually get rid of
those ghosts from the past well he
certainly is confronting Boris Johnson
directly in a way that he hasn't done
before until this week he's tend to just
not mention his predecessor at all and
now
um when he was in his speech a few days
ago he was saying well I wasn't
basically I wasn't going to promise um
something I wasn't going to be able to
deliver I.E in the endurance we get a
later peerage rather than an immediate
one so he has started to
um I think he thinks it's safe and I
think he's right to say but it is safe
to pick a fight with the remaining
Johnson Knights because there aren't
that many of them I mean the ones that
are there have basically resigned their
seats and caused him lots of violation
pain but as a faction in the political
party they are quite small so there
still is a path to victory for Richie
snake but that's a path which was always
narrow and it's got a lot more narrow in
the last few weeks previously you could
see his narrative it was well I came
leader when we were 30 points behind
labor now it's 15 points behind and if
we managed to get this to a 10 points
and deficit by the new year then the
election becomes contestable and who
knows what could happen but for that he
he needed a whole bunch of things to go
right he needed the Rwanda deportations
to start happening the small boats to um
stop
um arriving you needed inflation to have
by the way it's still forecast to have
but it's going to be a lot tighter than
you originally thought he needed the
Tories to stay um United behind the
belief that he might win if they behave
themselves and he needed the economy to
not collapse and at least give him the
ability to say that he had economic
prowess and that he would stop you know
your mortgage rate is going up all of a
sudden a bunch of these things are
looking a lot more questionable so that
narrow path has become even more narrow
still possible but
um I would say there's about a 20 25
chance of that happening now
now John let me look ahead to those free
by-elections to a definite Dean Doris is
taking her time she's considering her
options as I say in the cover piece and
one Minister asked um will Nadine Doris
just stay in the House of Commons now
until she gets that period almost a
threat to Rishi soon act to play ball
um but she may she may trigger her
by-election or at least start the
process so it goes near a Tory Party
Conference but working on the Assumption
we're heading to all three so at
Uxbridge Selby and mid bedfordshire
watching the Tory's chances are do you
think it is a reasonable expectation
scenario that they could lose all three
there's a risk that they could lose all
three but there's also a possibility
that they could at least hang on uh to
one of them perhaps not least because of
the reluctance of the opposition parties
uh to be able to come to an agreement
about how to divide the cake between
them
um Oxbridge looks by Far and Away the
most difficult to defend yes it's true
Lord Ashcroft did do a poll recently in
which he suggested that perhaps Boris
Johnson himself might be able to defend
the seed but the honest truth is you
know this is a constituency that we
would expect labor to win if they were
on course in them in a general election
uh to be winning an overall majority uh
the swing required is seven and a half
percent
um and the current swing in the opinion
polls is more of the order of 14 in
other words he needs little more uh
labeling little more than half the
current swing in the National polls and
sometimes of course the swinging by
elections is well the greater are done
in the National polls so I think Arts
Bridges by far away the most difficult
in contrast
both Selby and mid beverton and they're
both seats were labor start off second
but they start off a long second way of
uh Selby the swing required is 18 in mid
bedfordshire it's 19 so here we need if
labor are going to win the seat a bigger
swing than the current national polls
are pointing to and that so far is
something that labor have not managed to
achieve uh in this Parliament I mean
even in a victory uh such as Wakefield
we didn't see anything particularly
spectacular beyond the current position
of the parties in the opinion polls
um
so that but that said I mean again I
think there's no important distinction
between uh these uh two constituencies
Selby in mid bedfordshire
um Selby does have a record of Labor
voting in the past now it's you you have
to know your onions to spot it but
because Selby was only created as a
constituency in 2010 but if we go back
to the estimates that were made of what
would have happened in the constituency
if it had existed in 2005 they suggest
that labor would have only been four
points behind in the constituency and I
think therefore by inference Tony Blair
would probably have won it in 1997 and
2001. so you know not a constituency
would normally expect labor to win but
at least there is a recent history of
people in the area voting labor in not
inconsiderable numbers it's also by the
way a relatively strong Pro leave see
about 58 leave last time that you might
think is good news for conservatives no
it's not it's bad news it's very clear
here from the local elections now and we
know this also from what's going on in
the opinion polls the concerns are
losing ground more heavily the more
pro-leave a constituency is mid
bedfordshire it's not certainly not a
classic blue wall seat of the kind that
we say that would have got so focusing
on voted narrowly for brexit little
Democrats are a third however if you can
do the com do the go back all the way
back to 2005. this is a constituency
worth of what Democrats were ahead of
Labor in 2005. so labor in other words
have never done particularly well in
this constituency so you can see why the
liberal Democrats kind of fancy their
chances and look as though they're
determined to fight the seat hard in a
way that I suspect they will not find
Selby and the 64 000 question is what
will labor do labor are certainly saying
and I'm not surprised about this that
those implicit deals that were done over
Wakefield in Tiverton for example
they're not going to be done now because
of course labor want now to convince
people they can win a general election
and they can win big and kind of
standing down for one of your fellow
opponent opposition parties doesn't look
to be consistent that message so I
wouldn't be surprised if in the end both
of them fight hard as a result voters
don't necessarily work out which of the
two of them is better able to defeat the
conservatives and although the
conservative vote might go down quite
considerably this perhaps is the one
seat that in the end the conservatives
might hang on to so in other words
Nadine Doris may find that thanks to the
opposition she at least doesn't do quite
so much damage to what she saw like as
she intends finally Fraser do you think
Nadine will have her revenge
um
so I think Nadine will have her revenge
or she's taking it she's taking her
revenge now certainly but I think it's
your milk for for quite some time I'm
not sure how many people are going to be
swayed by her narrative as a little girl
from Liverpool all she ever wanted was a
place was the House of Lords and that
was cruelly denied her
um but I mean I I noticed it seems to me
to be the most indefensibly
self-indulgent I think they're I think
MPS should just not have the option of
getting bored and resigning halfway
through it's a serious thing standing
for Parliament if you're not prepared to
commit to your constituents to serve out
the term no matter what you shouldn't
have a goal to stand forward to election
so she's putting politics and distribute
let alone the conservative party so I
think Nadine really is not helping
herself and and she so I think
ultimately she will end up with more
damage on her reputation than Rishi
sunequal
Fraser thank you John
Boris Johnson is not the only blonde air
swad leader to be causing trouble this
week over the pond Donald Trump is in
court for holding on to classified
documents but the former president
claims he's a victim of a political
Witch Hunt
what should we make of it all joining me
now is spectator Deputy editor Freddie
Gray
Freddie thank you for joining spectator
TV this week great pleasure Katie we're
once again talking about Donald Trump
and the law and he has been in federal
court what is it on this occasion well
this is the classified document story
that has been rumbling uh for quite a
few months now
um and it exploded again quite
dramatically with the news that he is
going to be indicted on what finally
amounted to 37 counts
of federal crimes Federal uh criminal
allegations
the majority of which fall under the
Espionage Act which is to protect
National Security uh in relation to the
handling of these documents
the Espionage Act if he's found on any
one of these charges it is thought that
he could go to jail for 10 to 20 years
so if any one of about 20 21 22 charges
he could be spending the rest of his
life in jail and we've got use over the
years to just Trump always there's this
all this legal palava it just drags on
and on and on
um and he always gets away with it I
think there is some Justified excitement
from all the people that hate Trump that
this may be his final undoing because he
does appear to behave very recklessly
with these documents there are reports
again it's a lot of you have to be very
careful what you say because a lot of it
is motivated by people who desperately
want to bring him down but there's a lot
of talk about how he used to show off
about the documents you know tell people
what was in them even show people the
documents not just in Florida where this
trial is taking place but in in New
Jersey
and you can sort of Imagine Trump doing
that that's quite a trump thing to do to
say look I've got these secret files on
aliens or something like that you know
uh and uh so I think this may that it's
possible this may be the the thing that
gets drunk but even if it does
that will not stop in running
necessarily because somebody American
can run for president from jail it's
happened before in 1920 Eugene Debs did
it and got a million votes Donald Trump
would probably get a lot more votes than
that uh from prison but all all the
possibilities are open and at that point
so he won who's in jail could he just
simply pardon himself yes he could he
said that he won't or suggested that he
won't uh but he obviously would if he
was in jail and was President yes I mean
it's so ridiculous to think of it but
then every part of Donald Trump's
political story has been ridiculous
and Freddie in a way you'd be to me two
minutes question because you're saying
he can still run but I am reminded of
probably the last time we sat here for
spectator TV when it was yourself and
you know Ferguson and ultimately the
argument on The Spectator cover that
week and the argument you're both making
is all these court cases help Donald
Trump often the critics think that they
don't but they give them a lot of
publicity and they help them that
betrayal narrative
do you think this one falls into that
category or is it actually as you were
saying perhaps now more on the serious
side to the point that it isn't
necessarily going to be good for him
well it's very hard to read Because as
as no Ferguson said uh Neil Ferguson as
Neil Ferguson said uh the Curious
Dynamic is that the more these legal
problems put him in the public eye the
more his polling seems to tick up among
Republican voters and a lot of people I
had a piece trying to do it today a lot
of people say yes it motivates just his
base and it gets them all riled up the
crazy magar Army get all riled up but
it's very off-putting to Independence
I'm not sure the polls actually suggest
that's the case I think quite often
Independence or sort of trump leaning
people
go back to Donald Trump when they see
he's being persecuted legally and he is
being persecuted legally I mean that's
there's just no denying that he's being
he's being tried on many different
accounts because he is Donald Trump
that's not saying he hasn't done many
things wrong but he would not be being
hounded in this way if he wasn't Donald
Trump and it's an interesting point that
uh Douglas Murray talks about The
Spectator this week
um which is we are seeing across the
world um here we're speaking uh on a
week when Boris Johnson
is uh would have probably been pushed
out of parliament by his own MPS but the
police have been involved in party Gates
and had he not decided to step down
himself talking about political
assassination do you think we're seeing
more in terms of the law
um ultimately
affecting politicians in a way that
perhaps in the past it used to be
political rules well funnily enough I
was interviewing an Argentinian film
director yesterday and he said you're
becoming Latin America you're all
becoming Latin America because that's
what happens in Latin America is you
know people are presidents are arrested
the law is used as a political process
and it's happened in it happened in
Italy with Berlusconi who's just died he
spent most of his career a post
leadership facing a certain number of
legal cases
um it's happening in Scotland with
Nicholas sturgeon we remain to see what
happens there it's happened to a certain
extent with Boris Johnson it's a sort of
lower key less legal thing than Donald
Trump yeah of course initially police
say initially police there's a legal
element
um and it is it's lawfare uh as our
editor likes to call it it is uh it is
the use of the law or official privilege
you know parliamentary procedures
to make to remove someone from power or
to make it impossible for someone to win
back power uh I don't think that's very
Democratic I think with Boris Johnson uh
I think a lot of people would have been
quite happy to vote him out but that
should that should be how it was it
shouldn't be he's you know put away by a
court no of course he's slightly chose
himself by step she's in step down to
avoid the by-election where perhaps
people in his constituents at least
would have been able to have a say yeah
I mean I think you know in all of these
cases you can look at you know the
things that that person's done wrong the
things that the strategically they've
done wrong the things morally they've
done things legally they've done but the
bigger picture is this this wider trend
of
legal process is being used in a
political way
and go out to Trump just to conclude the
segment
what are the Democrats doing here is
Biden leaning into it much or just
keeping on and openly hoping it consumes
John Trump in a way whether he doesn't
have to get his hands dirty team button
is very sanguine about this uh and if
you're a conspiracy theorist and I sort
of am uh you think you're tin hand I'm
not going to wear the tin hat just to
make it look like I'm not okay next time
uh but if if uh if if by if Trump wins
the Republican nomination the Democrats
think that's good for them because they
think they can beat him and they think
since January 6th and the stormy of the
capital in 2021 they think that
Independents have drifted away from
Trump and he is now too politically
toxic for the majority and election
results would suggest there may be some
truth in that the midterms
high profile trumpy candidates failed
so they're quite happy with Trump being
the story because as far as they're
concerned it puts most Americans off the
extent the conspiracy stuff is the
extent to which they are actually
orchestrating this I tend to think
up actually to be honest I tend to think
up more than conspiracy in this
because I cannot believe that the
Democrats are as intelligent as to
orchestrate all these different
campaigns at the legal campaigns at the
same time uh however there is no denying
that the Department of Justice which is
led by President Joe Biden is very happy
to let this story dominate the headlines
great pleasure Katie
now when wildfires in Canada turned the
skies in New York orange and hazy news
reports almost universally blamed the
extreme weather event on climate change
but Lionel Shriver argues in her column
this week this is simply two lazy an
excuse
she joins the show now together with the
atmosphere scientist Professor Clifford
Mass
Lionel you're in New York When the Smoke
From the Canadian wildfires made it over
there but you didn't close the windows
why was that
well first off the the air from outside
was the same as their Insight I mean we
had to breathe something that's the way
it works so I didn't think keeping the
windows closed made much difference uh
more controversially I did go out and
play three hours of tennis each day that
the you know the doomsters were telling
us to hide in our beds and I lived to
tell the tale
so um
I mean I don't have asthma or anything
so uh it didn't seem that risky and the
point you make in your column uh
ultimately when it comes to These Bars
is that there is a tendency to blame
lots of these events on climate change
why is that well I've just noticed that
in the last few years especially uh
Whenever there is a weather event of any
sort it gets blamed I would have to say
quite lazily on climate change and uh in
the olden days meaning perhaps about
five years ago you would at least have
had to haul someone onto the news to
verify that who seem to know what he or
she was talking about but not anymore
um now we can just call anything that is
disagreeable in the atmosphere or the
geosphere uh climate change and
um I think that ultimately this
backfires because it starts to sound
like propaganda uh that's because it is
if it's not backed by any uh
causal science and uh it starts to sound
like background noise I know I realize
that this is politically motivated and
that we're supposed to be convinced that
not only is climate change somewhere off
in the future but it's happening right
now
um but
uh because because the attribution is so
careless uh it it doesn't actually help
the cause and in the case of the
wildfires it's it's just inaccurate uh
they were started by lightning strikes
uh the wind then blew very hard in an
unfortunate Direction and therefore a
lot of little fires that were started
that would have otherwise gone out got
fanned
um and then there was this weird high
pressure low pressure high pressure
thing over North America which is
apparently a rather unusual construction
didn't have anything to do with climate
change it's called an Omega block
um and that explained why that all that
smoke ended up coming to the Eastern
Seaboard but you know all over New York
um media of newscasters and and
colonists and even the mayor of New York
just said you know this is this is all
because of climate change and you know
if you don't mind my saying so they're
talking out of their r's
Cliff do you agree with that
well most of the things I agree with all
although one thing I would disagree with
was but the air quality it was very bad
at points I mean extremely serious air
quality and playing tennis outside in
that air was probably not a good idea
okay I admit it was a little stupid that
that wasn't a good idea and the other
thing is and the air inside the building
could if it had a circular circular
circulation system going on like air
conditioning or whatever it would have
filtration that would have made the air
a lot better inside so so just as a as
some advice you know you don't have air
conditioning there's no circulation at
all there's no uh if you have a heating
system you put it on uh you put you shut
the heat down but let it recirculate air
that can make the air much much better
so anyway so that that's just a general
comment but I mean the other issues that
wyanl pointed out I wouldn't disagree
with them in the uh there's been a
tremendous amount of hype climate change
implication for almost every extreme
weather event and most of it is not
scientifically based it's hype and
exaggeration and I'm saying this is
someone who who works on this in an
intimate way
and Lionel just just on the heating a
housekeeping there for viewers regular
viewers of spectator TV they'll know
that you're not one to regularly use
your heating system yes
no we're not running our heating system
and certainly not when it's you know 72
degrees Fahrenheit
um which to me is after after the winter
without heating is Toasty
but the secret is to turn the heat off
and let the fan go and that can be that
can really improve your air so that
that's that's something you might think
about
thanks for the tip yeah
now let's go back to the column Lionel
you make another point which is actually
government regulation could have been a
factor in this can you explain what it
is in terms of controlled fires well
this is uh from a report in the New York
Times
um
which is very raw raw on climate change
so this is admission against interest
but one of the problems going on in
Canada uh is in order to do a controlled
burn you have to get through this
Thicket of regulations and it's so
difficult and it's so time consuming
that the narrow window of of
ideal conditions it needs to be
relatively still and not too hot
um
that that window closes by the time you
get through all the paperwork so uh
they're doing a lot of fewer controlled
Burns than they used to and
you know they're they're underfunding
the
um forest service and uh
they're just not doing a very good job
of managing their forests and
it's very similar to the problem in
California
which is doing exactly the same thing
and that's of course the the land of
Regulation not cliff do you think there
is a tendency with some of these um
events that come up to almost talk about
it in terms of climate change which
clearly can be a factor and when some of
the time at least uh sometimes can be
government handling government
preparedness government regulations and
it almost can distract from that type of
accountability
well it depends what you're talking
about
um in in terms of the uh the forest
issues the wildfires this is one in
which uh government mismanagement on
both sides of the Border have profoundly
undermined the situation so it's just
not Canada the United States I'm very
aware what's happening in California
Pacific Northwest
and the the forests are radically
different than they were 150 years ago
and a lot of that is due to you know
suppression of fire not allowing Harvest
of the of the trees we have a forests
that used to be sparsely populated now
are densely populated with this
understory and they burn
catastrophically now so so for the From
The Far Side
mismanagement is is is right in the
center of it all
um you know that's going to be less of a
case in in other extreme weather events
you know like a heat wave or a cold wave
the the government intervention is is
less profound
this do you think in the scientific
Community there is a consensus there or
views like this approaching
uncontroversial in the forest community
and I know people and I go to all the
talks you know there there is a
consensus that we have mismanaged the
forests in the Western United States and
other places so I think the Forest
Community the the forestry Community I
there is a consensus of course if you go
out of that Community into the climate
change Community or the climate
activists uh there's a consensus in the
opposite direction
and Lionel just finally uh do you think
that there should be more transparency
or Clarity from world leaders when it
comes to talking about the causes of
some of these uh incidents in a sense
for example I'm thinking of some of the
comments recently from Justin Trudeau I
would have more regard for the messaging
if it were more nuanced
and uh and it isn't it isn't ever and
when you constantly attribute every
single
rained off picnic
to climate change you make people
dubious of your expertise
um
and
that's my main message this stuff is
backfiring
um
and my other main message is that we're
losing an appreciation for the
difference between climate and weather
now it's true that climate in the great
big picture is this the sum total of all
the weather
but we do have two different words for a
reason and the most interesting thing
about writing this column for me was
looking up a graph of the temperature of
the earth which they have you know
geologists have put together uh over the
last half a million years and it was
fascinating and one of the things that's
fascinating is first off the the
amplitude that is a huge variation in
the average temperature and also the
regularity with which every hundred
thousand years the temperature
swoops down and goes down to about five
degrees Celsius
and then it
goes steeply up again
and we we have been on one of those
steep upward trajectories for the last
22 000 years
and almost all of that time was without
any
um industrialization no no gas powered
power plants
um
and that gave me a sense of respect for
the bigger system that we're constantly
commenting on and in truth the periods
of time that we're talking about are
geologically
almost non-existent and
while I'm uh I try to keep an open mind
on this whole issue
uh I find that the perspective I get
from taking
of step back and looking at
the last half million years I find it
um I find it refreshing and it makes me
um keep an eye outside all the rhetoric
um can I comment on that yeah please do
sure a Lionel you know I understand what
you're saying but what you're saying is
not quite right and you've got to be
very careful here
um you know there we have this
variability due to ice ages over long
periods of time
um and that's true there's all kinds of
sources of variability there's this ice
age and out of the Ice Age so the
interglacials uh there's El Nino La Nina
a smaller periods of time there's all
kinds of Cycles in the atmosphere but
that doesn't mean the global warming
issue is not a real one
um it is true that greenhouse gases will
warm the planet and can warm it
relatively quickly so I mean we got to
be careful this because there's been
variations that doesn't mean we don't
have to worry about the issue I think
the the the key understanding here is
that global warming is slowly warming
the planet we are slowly warming the
planet but that is not necessarily
producing this whole collection of
extremes
that the media is has has fixated on the
I I like to use the term the golden rule
of of uh climate change and that is the
greater the extreme
the smaller percentage of it is from
climate change natural variability can
produce extremes and so you know we we
go in and out of ice ages that's true
but that does not mean that human cause
global warming is not something that we
should ignore or is or is absolutely
unimportant uh I I think there's a
middle ground here where the truth is I
broadly agree that that there is a
middle ground and if we heard more from
the Middle Ground
um
the the messaging would be more
persuasive I think we're being treated
like idiots
thank you Lionel thank you cliff
next in his article this week Owen
Matthews asked the question where's
Putin the Russian president has made
public appearances when it comes to
making decisions in the war or rebutting
as critics Putin seems to be shrinking
into the background
Owen joins me now together with the
Russian American journalist
whose latest book is hybrid Warriors out
now
Owen Anna thank you for joining
spectator TV this week oh and in your
piece of the magazine you have some
quite catty quotes about Putin but
they're not from any Western leaders
this isn't the Americans this isn't the
ukrainians they're from nationalists
Russians
yes you're getting pregosian has outdone
himself he's the billionaire former
caterer and founder of the Wagner group
and um he's emerged as actually one of
the most weirdly enough realistic
um and articulate voices criticizing the
Russian war effort and what he said is
that the ukrainians are a formidable foe
they're fighting well and honorably
Russia is losing the war strategically
and in order not to lose it according to
igeon they need to Institute Institute
Mass mobilization and actually put the
whole of Russia on a serious War footing
and also execute the Minister of Defense
that's progressions
what going quite extreme already there
and then is it true that the Wagner
group have even kidnapped and beat up
um Russian army figure yeah I mean
what's been happening over the last 10
days with Wagner is extraordinary I mean
it's it's almost a beyond belief the the
the the the the extent of the what the
Russians
they're just completely out of control
yeah so they they kidnap the commander
of a battalion as Lieutenant Colonel
beat him up forced him to do a prisoner
style hostage Style video confessing to
ordering the shelling of Wagner troops
while he was drunk then when he was
released this Colonel said by the way
Wagner regularly torture kidnap and the
uh Russian troops and steal our
ammunition and stuff so little surprise
that yesterday you know Putin's actually
put his you know
put his imprimatur on trying to reign in
Wagner but so far Wagner is showing
those signs of of
of submitting to Putin's word
um Anna in the past you've talked about
some of these interventions from the
head of the wagon group and like them to
temper tantrums do you think that's
still the case
um I I think that's still the case but I
think what's what's increasingly
interesting is
um look in in Russia at the moment
there's such a deep climate of uh
anxiety and paranoia that you cannot say
things out loud you cannot say
Putin you've made a mistake
uh and you can't to the extent that you
can't even for some people you can't
even admit this to yourself and I think
that in some ways what uh pagosian may
be doing is uh basically
in so many words saying look you have to
you have to decide because you you've
clearly made a mistake either you uh
mobilize
and you you know do a real war
um or you back out and you know I'm not
really sure and I don't think anybody
can really tell to what extent pregosian
is actually considering maybe this
wasn't the way to go at all uh this this
invasion was
um a failure
um and I think this is very interesting
because uh this is uh in very many ways
what's what stroke off is doing and I
think this kind of goes back to a
pattern of uh Vladimir Putin relying on
people he thinks of as friends uh who
will do his bidding like stroke off back
in 2014 and now like pragosian
um and then it turns out that they have
their own agendas and they actually
believe in things that Putin doesn't
necessarily believe in uh and that comes
back against him it uh he ends up
alienating uh these um uh forces that
that he relies on these forces turn
against him and they start basically
saying very much the same things as the
opposition as Alexei navalny and that
puts puts it in a real bind and I think
that kind of explains why uh he has been
so silent because what do you say to
this
is tracheon because ever since I think
the first day of the invasion there are
lots of figures saying Putin will come
to regret this he's going to face
pressure within Russia and it's always
obviously hard from an outside
perspective to get a sense of how much
pressure he is under and also uh of
course if we were talking about a
western leader being under pressure so
we'll wait to the next election that's
going to really show them so so if Putin
is under pressure
what does that look like in terms of
consequences
well we have to understand that actually
for a leader whose capital was just
struck by a drone attack to drone
strikes on the credential May 3rd then
between 8 and 30 drone strikes on some
of the most prestigious real estate in
Suburban Moscow in late May early June I
mean you this level of criticism for any
in any normal political system is
amazingly little what's remarkable about
what we're talking about is the fact
that there has been no criticism and the
fact that Russia represses any kind of
criticism so fiercely I mean there are
dozens of Russians in jail literally for
holding up posters and Facebook posts
and suddenly you have these two you know
at least two very prominent programming
or other nationalist voices like like
precaution coming out and basically you
know calling for something pretty close
to Revolution I mean it's extraordinary
um doesn't mean that
um Putin is under serious threat from
these people I think not for a very
simple reason and that is let's say
pregosian controls an army of 50 000 uh
should I go and the Kremlin control uh
an army if you include all the police
and paramilitary police of about three
and a half million so you know
precaution is not about to take over the
Kremlin that's not the the terms in
which we should be looking at this the
the question is really what happens if
Putin faces a serious military defeat in
the field I mean the early indications
are that
um the offensive is going much more
slowly than anticipated you know the
jury's out we don't know how far the
ukrainians are going to get but let's
say they do make significant advances
then Putin's going to become under more
and more pressure not from the liberal
opposition whose voices are you know
basically non-existent in modern
political Russian discourse but from the
ultra nationalists that's those are the
people who actually form the most scary
and most potent threat to Putin
energy agree with that uh yes I uh I
think that uh the danger that they pose
is not so much that uh pregosian is
going to rise up and actually do
something uh not at all because we have
to understand that this is a uh unlike
shoigu who he's uh criticizing and he's
attacking pregosian has absolutely no
State mandate he has very little
institutional power and you know even in
a personal system like Putin's
institutional power matters a lot
percussion has none that said the damage
that he can do is and people uh like him
can do is uh calling things by the
rightful names calling this a war that
is failing and
um that I think is
um
really the the problem that that Putin
is facing because if he uh if he kind of
calls out pregosian and and tries to
shut him down he's only going to look
like he's trying to suppress I mean he
it's going to make him look weak and
stupid
um and this is um
kind of what's really putting him in in
this
uh in this place of strategic paralysis
where you can't really take
um either step either to uh kind of temp
term pregosian and the nationalists
um or uh uh do do as they say uh either
way he's kind of in a loss he's facing
uh massive uh risks from any scenario
any step he takes
um and I think in that in that continued
situation you know by doing nothing at
all he's also continuing this uh he's
continuing he is leading to the
nationalists continuing to criticize him
and basically call him out for not doing
anything so
um
I mean I think he is in a way losing
control in in the state of mind if if we
if we see some changes on the
battlefield soon uh he'll react to that
but at this point he's faced with
difficult decisions and he's just not
going to make them
and just finally I wondered do you think
there is a sense
um when it comes to the Russian
perspective if they hang on long enough
geopolitical factors can start to work
in their favor because one thing we
talked about on spectator TV of course
is a potential Donald Trump returned to
the White House he's made plenty of
comments you never quite know how
seriously to take them but it certainly
seems to be the read that Donald Trump
would be less committed than Joe Biden
as to helping Ukraine when it comes to
the war effort and without America
having a big involvement that could mean
that other Western countries could
struggle to have much impact even if
they wanted to help and that could
change quite a lot yeah I I think that's
absolutely uh correct and and for Putin
it's it's by no means the the the worst
strategy in fact is more or less the
only available strategy which is just to
hang on for as long as possible wait for
the ukrainians to exhaust their
offensive uh and just watch the poll
numbers because already there's a pollen
in Italy back in May that showed that
support for arming Ukraine was down to
34 in Germany support farming Ukraine is
down 11 year on year the poll the polls
despite their political support for
Ukraine have just banned the import of
Ukrainian grain uh two months ago and
you know clearly and of course you have
both U.S candidates for the U.S
Republican Presidential uh nomination
you know who are Ukraine's skeptical to
say the very least uh so you know the
moment this stops becoming a United sort
of Western
issue of principle and becomes a
domestic political issue then Ukraine is
in trouble and in fact Ukraine already
is in trouble insofar as I think it's
clear that this was the last shopping
round for Vladimir zielinsky uh that
he's not going to come back and ask for
more and receive for more main battle
tanks I mean he said zielinski said
three weeks ago that this war could go
on for years and decades but there's
zero appetite in the West for that to
happen so in that sense Putin is not
crazy in just trying to
outweight the west and assume that
wherever the front lines are at the end
of this year beginning of next year
whenever it is that the West decides to
wrap this all up that that's what he's
going to get is good to keep
thank you Erin thank you Anna
and we have a new offer for The
Spectator magazine if you subscribe
today you'll not only get your first
month free
but after your triangle page is one
final week for full access to your
website and app or two pounds a week if
you want the print magazine too
to claim this offer go to
spectator.co.uk forward slash best
finally our boys boarding skills a Dying
Breed only six remain as even other
traditional schools like Winchester and
Westminster have said that they're
planning on going co-ed is this all for
the best
I'm joined by a former teacher at Radley
College Andrew Cunningham he's written
about it for spectator life
Andrew thank you for joining spectator
TV this week thank you very much for
having me now you write for spectator
life about boys boarding schools now we
can list a few world famous hopefully
probably start to offend people if we
miss theirs out Eaton Harrow and more
but yet you say they're actually a Dying
Breed tell us more yeah I've been in
boarding schools for about 30 years now
and it's really been interesting how
they've evolved over that time and
particularly recently
um obviously they've struggled for
numbers in the past particularly well at
the start of my career in the 90s yeah
they were a lot of these playing quite
famous names obviously not eaten uh
we're going on because they were just
relying on boys and it was a
some might say brought cynical move to
taking girls without ever having thought
it through you know some of the
logistics of that but what I'm detecting
now um with the latest news about
Charter House Westminster Winchester all
very famous names all big schools very
historic
um there's a there's a shift now because
of um uh it's becoming much less the
Zeitgeist I think to have just all boys
Schools they're going to co-ed for
different reasons I can't imagine
they're short of numbers what do you
think is going on in terms of the
motivation for that is it parents
actually thinking we'd rather our child
have an education with children from
other gender yeah I think that's that's
a big part of it logistically it's much
easier it seems much more natural
obviously from parental points of view
especially if they've got you know um
boys and girls I think everyone's
invited made a big impact 20 what was it
2020 uh June 2020 and a lot of these
schools just for every school well-known
boarding school and Day School indeed
like Westminster uh were very much
accused of of the kind of sexism that um
and I think that has certainly played a
part certainly in westminster's dishes
disability say that on their website
they're quite open about it you know we
need to be a little more diverse and I
suspect that's played a part in
Winchester's decision as well I think
Chart House were already going co-ed but
they're the kind of big three that have
recently got so I think there's
different
factors motivating that you know a need
to just be more normal as it were I've
worked in
that's called single sex girls single
sex boys co-ed and and co-ed is you know
this is quite normal you mentioned the
um earlier some of the criticism of
course same-sex girls have received yeah
but I wondered
um and we'll go on obviously to the
positives of uh ultimately having
covered schools but do you think
anything is potentially being lost in
the sense of you know what having worked
in some of these schools do you think
are the most positive things about
having a single sex School in terms of
perhaps all male or or female focus and
lack of distraction like that I mean
just better grades yeah and better
grades and I mean it's a classroom
teacher it's a lot easier to get say
boys teenage boys focused in a boys only
Club they tend to show off you know
teenage boys age 15 they grow out of it
by the time they're in the sixth form
yeah but they show off
I think a slight generalization but you
can detect that and I think it's true
um
single sex girls I talk to North London
Collegiate as well that's really
interesting very bright girls and and
maybe they they were the results were
astronomically good but maybe they
just occasionally could have benefited a
little bit more from a little bit more
you know kind of rough and tumble in a
good way you know um with um with the
opposite um
sex in terms of mixed schools do you
think one gender benefits more from
having the other in the classroom then
if girls potentially I know more cans
taking their studies more seriously
obviously this is a sweep in general
yeah it's I think at a level
um it I mean it's quite interesting my
own subject so it's like
digress but numbers are plummeting with
boys because the boys now are doing stem
subjects a slight generalization they're
being pushed by a lot of factors in
society and prepare parents to do stem
subjects so English lets my subject is
seen as a soft skill uh where it's still
very popular amongst um girls and I
think girls really pull on boys pull
along Boys in that particular subject
you know because there's so much more
independent research focused and
self-starting clearly all male schools
have been a part of almost British
culture for some time yeah and now if we
do you think we'll get to an appointment
they all die out or actually would you
bet good money on eating staying as it
is well you never know with eating
because they they like to pull you know
um tricks and surprise us all I mean I
think some of the attributes of boys
because like rugby you know compulsory
rugby that is the Better or For Worse
perhaps uh dying and obviously sport now
is much more inclusive
um it's not like the old Sports so much
um I can see that very soon the next 10
years there's going to be just one or
two all boys Public Schools left it'll
be a question of which one uh I think
that's quite hard to call because Ethan
it would seem the obvious one to stay
all boys but you never quite know
because they're always coming up with
initiatives and doing things sometimes
publicity perhaps yeah
are there any other countries that are
leaders in all male schools um yeah well
traditionally of course New England uh
in America and um Virginia have been
mirroring the British boarding schools
so there's a very similar pattern the
America's actually led the way on Co-Ed
I think in um what they call prep
schools you know um preparatory schools
you've got you know various a number of
very well-known schools choke Rosemary
Hall
um Groton John Hopkins Kent College uh
modeled on English boarding school lines
and they all started off for single sex
uh but they started that training I
think in the 70s and 80s of going co-ed
so there's not yet a country ready to
take the bet on if uh Britain is
declared and all it's all male schools
um well they won't close down the
schools obviously they'll just have
girls and I mean they're the numbers are
booming I mean that's the going co-head
is absolutely solving the numbers
problem thank you Andrew for joining us
beta TV today thank you for having me
that's it for
this once again thank you to Canada
called genuity wealth management for
sponsoring the week in 60 minutes can
Accord will provide you with the
expertise you need to help you build
your wealth of confidence visit can do
wealth.com for more information
thanks again for watching and do join us
again next week
[Music]